احتفل ملايين السعوديين امس بيوم العلم
هذه المناسبه الوطنيه لصدر امر ملكي
بخصوصها فامر الملك سلمان بتخصيص يوم 11
مارس من كل عام للعلم الوطني وتسميه هذا
اليوم بيوم العالم وهذا الاحتفال جاء
انطلاقا من قيمه العلم الممتده عبر تاريخ
الدوله السعوديه منذ تاسيسها واللي بيرمز
بشهاده التوحيد في وسطه الى رساله السلام
والاسلام والسيف طبعا بيرمز للقوه والانفه
وعلو الحكمه والمكانه ووزارات ومؤسسات
حكوميه نظمت احتفالات بالمناسبه تضمنت رفع
العلم وتشغيل اغاني وطنيه هذا غير
المؤسسات الخاصه كمان اللي احتفلت
بالطريقه نفسها وطبعا الطلاب والطالبات في
المدارس احتفلوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مقاطع الاحتفالات والفيديوهات التي تم
تداولها في يوم العالم كثيره لكن يمكن
اللي كانوا ملفتين اكثر من غيرهم مقاطع من
قمم جبال عاليه في مختلف بقاع المملكه رفع
عليها المواطنين العالم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تم رفع العالم السعودي في يوم العلم 11
مارس 2023
باعلى قمه جبل الطارقي
ارتفاع تقريبا 930 متر مربع
[موسيقى]
روحي وما ملكك
الحبيب وهل احب وغير القمم كمان في
الاعماق في شباب سعوديين غاصو حاملين
العلم محتفله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موضوع احتفالات يوم العلم ومقاطعها وصورها
الدوله السعوديه بشكل واسع ويمكن من اكثر
المواضيع اللي تم تداولها صور بتظهر تاريخ
تطور العالم السعودي من بدايه الدوله
السعوديه الى يومنا هذا
الاحتفالات بيوم العالم كمان تضمنت تدشين
موقع الكتروني رسمي للعلم السعودي في كل
التفاصيل اللي يحتاجها اي احد عن العلم
وتم كمان تدشين حساب على تويتر ليوم
العالم اريد صار جامع الاف المتابعين
وبيغرد الحساب بمعلومات عن العلم السعودي
ومن المقاطع الملفته حقيقه اللي نشرها
الحساب هو الفيديو اللي راح تشوفوه الان
واللي مرفق معاه كمان كتيب بيتضمن
بروتوكول وضوابط وارشادات استخدام العالم
العلم لها احترام بروتوكولاته ما يجوز ابد
تنكيسه ولا يعلى عليه علم ومكانه دايم
مكان الشرف ولاننا نفخر به علمنا حاضر في
كل المناسبات والمحافل في المنصات
والمكاتب وواجهه المباني وحتى السيارات
والسفن وكلها لها ضوابط وتعليمات وحتى في
العرض السعوديه البيرق له تقاليده ومكانه
وحاملها يكون في صف المؤدي شايل للعلم
بشماله والعلم على كتف الايمن وحتى طيب
العلم لازم يكون بشكل لائق وخطوات محدده
مثلا يكون في مكان مناسب وما تدلى اطرافه
وتلمس الاخ هذا علمنا وهذه بعض ارشاداته
وما يكفي اللي عرفته اطلع الحين على
الدليل الارشادي لاستخدام علم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتصفح الموقع الالكتروني
واحتفل وافخر بعلمنا باللي يليق فيه ويعكس
هيبته